I'm sorry I'm not there at the moment
I'm very busy however many happy returns
I'm gonna be with you again very soon
hey youtubers Happy New Year so many
awesome things happen during 2013 that I
wanted to try and just put it all into
perspective before Sherlock comes back
tomorrow first things first I want to
say high-fives
to everyone whether you subscribe to me
from day one or you just found me now
originally when I started I just wanted
to find other people to talk about all
my favorite sci-fi and fantasy stuff
with and 70000 and people later I think
I can safely say that we're on the right
track I also want to say a big thank you
to my friends at Nerdist for supporting
my channel the people at BBC America for
all the help you did during Doctor Who
week in the 50th anniversary along with
the people at HBO because I know 2014 is
gonna be a big year for Game of Thrones
it's gonna be a lot of fun but here are
10 amazing facts from 2013 and things
that I'm really grateful for and a few
stories that I haven't told yet
number one it all started with Doctor
Who and the snowmen my first real video
was for the 2012 Doctor Who Christmas
special the snowmen if you haven't seen
it it is embarrassing I'd actually been
earning a living on YouTube since 2010
but had never really taken the time to
make any of my own videos just a hundred
percent by myself and I thought you know
god damnit this episode is going to be
awesome and I'm gonna go find some other
youtubers to talk about it with since
that time I hope you can see how much
better
everything looks that early stuff is
really raw but it definitely got me
started number two there was absolutely
no plan at the start in the first couple
of months I did like maybe one video a
week and it was right when community
season 4 started in that season did not
turn out too great
but once Doctor Who and Game of Thrones
got started things really got going
jumping back to now I can say I'm
definitely more proud of myself for
finding shows and sticking with them
week to week I know every once in a
while I'll miss an episode but only
because some much bigger event comes
along
number three it's gotten way more fun
when I first got started I got super
stressed out about how I put videos
together and what they looked like and
eventually I just figured out that that
does not matter at all what really
matters is just the conversation that
you guys and I have and just that that's
fun and insightful number four I started
making a lot more videos when I first
started I would do like maybe one Doctor
Who video and won Game of Thrones video
week and then maybe like a bonus video
but now I'm up to almost 10 videos a
week so I'm spending a lot more time
doing work on YouTube remember I still
do have a full-time job so I'm at like
maybe 80 maybe sometimes like 90 hours a
week on YouTube because my full-time job
is the YouTube job but it's not work
it's totally fun and I would not do it
if it weren't number 5 it may have
started with a TARDIS but it was really
dragons that got my channel started so
even though those first couple of videos
were Doctor Who videos it was really
once Game of Thrones got started last
spring that things really took off that
was really what forced me to start
making better videos and focusing more
on the conversations I was having with
you guys I don't know what it's gonna
look like whenever a game of Thrones
comes back in the spring but I can tell
you just in the last couple of months my
channel has doubled in size twice so I
am really excited for 2014 I have
absolutely no idea what's gonna happen
but it is going to be amazing number six
by the numbers so during 2013 I actually
ended up making about 264 videos and if
you counted all the time that we watched
them it would take 32 million two
hundred forty six thousand two hundred
and ninety minutes or about sixty one
and a half years that's a lot of time to
watch video but just to give me an idea
over 95 percent of that giant number
happened after comic-con 2013
number seven the summer of comic-con
there are so many awesome things about
comic-con and just conventions in
general but I have this crazy comic-con
story that I don't think I've ever told
so the hardest part about comic-con
isn't navigating the floor or paying the
exorbitant prices that people charge for
merchandise or even just getting into
panels it's actually just getting a
ticket and I was not able to get a
ticket last year so how the hell did I
get in a friend found a friend who is
selling a ticket that person is actually
a cast member on Felicia days guilt show
so if any geek and sundry people ever
come to me needing anything I will
totally help them out because I owe them
big so if you ever wonder how I got all
those awesome comic-con videos done
earlier this year during the summer it's
all indirectly because of geek and
sundry they are awesome number eight the
second half of 2013 so it kind of
divided 2013 until like the first half
in the second half because there were so
many big changes that happen in the sec
in half I started making more videos I
started making them faster I started
making them better so I really like to
think of the first half of 2013 as like
my WTF phase where I was trying to
figure out just what the hell I was
doing with my channel that is with the
exception of one giant event that
happened at the end of November number
nine the Doctor Who 50th anniversary so
backtrack just a little bit in case you
missed it during the summer after Comic
Con YouTube did this really big thing
called geek week where a bunch of giant
channels did all this really nerdy
awesome video stuff after that I
hallucinate it that it would be an
awesome idea to do a Doctor Who version
of that just on a smaller scale so I had
my friends at Nerdist meet with the
people at the BBC to see if BBC was
interested in supporting an event like
that and lo and behold they were just as
excited about it as we were and they
wanted to do it for the 50th anniversary
it was actually either going to be the
50th anniversary or we were gonna do it
for the Christmas special so if you ever
wonder where this TARDIS actually came
from the BBC sent it to me as a
thank-you for kind of inspiring Doctor
Who week and my brain just exploded it
went so much better than I ever could
have hoped number 10 things that I'm
most thankful for this year to be honest
I'm mostly thankful for all of you guys
for just supporting all the crazy ideas
that I had it seems like every week I
hallucinate something new to do like
anime club or wholock week and you guys
always rush in to give me a high five I
try to give away as much free stuff as
possible just as a way to say thank you
but honestly I'm mostly plan on spending
2014 trying to repay you guys by just
making videos that you really like to
watch if there's anything that I'm
really trying to do with this it's just
make videos that are fun and help us
think new things about the stuff that we
like and kind of help us meet new people
so giant high five and if there's
anything that you guys want to try out
in 2014 on the channel just let me know
in the comments below and I'll try it
work it in I'm always open to new ideas
and I'd love to hear what you guys think
real quick reminder Sherlock episode 1
premieres tomorrow on Wednesday I'll be
posting a non-spoilery review of that
and then a couple days after that I'll
do a Q&A video and a breakdown where I
can answer you guys questions just in
case you're not able to find it right
away don't worry I'll have clear spoiler
warnings on all the videos that I do for
it also this week community is back on
Thursday get excited for that Dan
Harmon's back it's going to be crazy
season and on Saturday is anime
Club that's gonna be my next giveaway so
congrats to my last two lakh week winner
that's from the last video I did this
weekend but don't worry next giveaway
starts anime club on Saturday right now
prepare thyself for Sherlock by clicking
here to learn about my Sherlock lives
theory and you can click here to get my
top 5 anticipated moments for season 3
careful there might be a few small
spoilers in there thank you so much for
watching
Happy New Year's high fives I'll see you
guys tomorrow for Sherlock